je vous propose de tourner aujourd'hui
votre séparation
comme ça on l'aura
la première est diffusée qu'en vous
sépare
interview séparation
qu'est ce que vous vouliez plus
supporter chez lui son malaise
alors regardez je suis toujours
légèrement de côté par
son haleine qui me sur jan voss c'est
vrai que sur caméra café à la fin vous
parlez que pendant les prises et encore
dans les prisons s'arranger pour passe
par les non plus on ne prenait des
doublures
paris pendant lés prises sur caméra café
bon bah ouais non mais il ya un moment
c'est plus possible que les gens qui ont
toujours besoin d'être rassurés admirer
encensé c'est fatigant quoi je ne sais
pas un moment pour se prendre par la
main et puisse assumer en tant qu'être
humain avec ses défauts et puis et puis
voilà et pas être habitué toujours à ce
comptable et dans le matin et à te
déplaît un tapis rouge les tuteurs c'est
moi c'est ça qui m'embête et shelly
c'est ce côté ces difficultés qu'il a à
faire des phrases simples par exemple
à partir de quand c'est devenu
insupportable avec lui
à partir du moment où il a fait la
dernière de libération la dernière c'est
la dernière page de libération fait mal
ceci dit elle fait la couverture était
les cassettes et j'ai regardé mois
finalement c'est un soulagement dans
cette séparation
un soulagement non pas tant que ça parce
qu'on a quand même eu de très très bons
moments ouais ça aurait eu un moment les
gens applaudissaient ouais hein maman à
la maman les gens applaudissaient
[Applaudissements]
et vous comprenez la meilleure façon de
séparer deux amis c'est de mettre un tas
de dollars entre les deux voilà y'a rien
qui résiste c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est le problème vous êtes fier comme
de ce que vous allez faire en son nom
sur le début
après c'était apprécié et et c'était
l'intérêt c'était pour le public ouais
by par le public depuis que voulait nous
faire à deux donc c'est 3-2 mais s'ils
savaient tenu qu'à moi je serais parti
dès le début
mais cela des chances de vous revoir
ensemble ce n'est pas possible
le téléthon le téléthon le téléthon le
sien alors
j'ai pas bien et donnait un coup de main
s'il est un petit coup de mots un
voulurent connaissez bien qu'à une
qualité quand maman à temps ben ils
portent ils portent comme des rafles et
merde il porte comme mes rouflaquettes
comme personne un même ça il sait pas le
dire
c'est pas tout le monde il ya eu mungo
jerry buss
oui mais quoi si vous lui parlez encore
eux
tu es encore là
et vous mais je dirais va dormir avec la
chemise de blaireaux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu